we're a robots made of robots made of
robots made of robots you've got
billions several hundred billion
probably cells neurons in your brain
each one of those neurons is a
eukaryotic cell with nucleus and with
with mitochondria and it's it's a direct
descendant of free swimming free living
autonomous little single-celled
organisms that have been around for
billions of years and if you look inside
each neuron you find that there are
motor proteins and the like little
little power motor protein is certainly
a robot it's not alive but it's it's a
bit of nano engineering that does all
sorts of interesting work it's mindless
and that's what that's what we're made
of now in a way when you think about it
that way you realize how sort of
outrageously ambitious it is to to make
a humanoid robot that has the power of a
human brain when the the the individual
the modeling of the individual neurons
is is extremely crude compared to what
the brain can do I mean the the brain
has has literally literally trillions
and trillions of moving parts the most
elaborate robot yet conceived and
Counting the the chip as a collection of
moving parts doesn't have trillions of
moving parts it's by orders of magnitude
simpler
you